first she wasn't elected now Hillary's
class gets rejected true even students
on the left give Professor Clinton an F
students in Hillary Clinton's new class
says it
sucks even more than an intern
who ah you know where this is going but
it's the smartest realization on campus
since someone realized you could put
vodka up your butt thanks Shannon
U earlier this year Bill's Work or half
accepted a professorship at Colombia
teaching public affairs meanwhile Bill
did offer to tutor some of the female
students but Columbia has a no cigar
policy the left praised Hillary for
passing her wisdom onto the next
Generation on everything from fraudulent
land deals to unflattering pants suits
meanwhile students were promised
empowering lessons by one of America's
biggest losers after all who else can
teach him how to delete emails and
Destroy evidence while also learning how
to destroy l Libya but turns out the
class is just a bunch of ego worshipping
driil in front of an audience unlike her
show on Apple TV which was ego
worshipping driil without an audience
one disappointed student described her
first day as a swarm of several hundred
people a sea of cameras Secret Service
Personnel sounds like every time Joe
makes a boom
boom they're very happy when it happens
the student likened the experience to
attending a late night talk show as
opposed to an intimate College lecture
which isn't fair Hillary's way funnier
than Kimmel but you know the class is
bad when even left-wing students vocally
trashed it who then all mysteriously
wound up
dead I guess hammers aren't just for
smashing hard drives but it's okay
she'll tell their families that it was
suicide oh boy wake up people all right
cat y uh you almost went to to Columbia
yep that's good enough for me what uh
yeah I I couldn't afford it that's why I
didn't go um what do you make of the
fact that they were just these stupid
kids are actually disappointed and
shocked no no no this I read this whole
article that this student wrote and she
is being
ridiculous she's saying she didn't do
any office hours and she didn't grade
our papers and regardless of what your
title is you it's like did you really
think Hillary Clinton was going to read
your papers I bet you like she people
have a hard time getting her to read the
books that they write for her and put
her name on them like it's Hillary
Clinton you're being Absolut this
student thought she was going to like
meet Hillary Clinton and they were going
to like galp around town in the class
that's but I did it like when I actually
when I was just a average variety Garden
variety Food Service employee and
because I was supposed to be at Columbia
but I couldn't afford it I watched red
eye and I was like if I could just meet
that little man he would love me
and then I could work for him but I was
right yeah it very rarely happens well
you were talking about Eric Shawn no I'm
talking about you buddy I'm talking
about you I was like I'd be so good on
this show just just give me in the room
with this guy and you hired a weird food
service fan that is true that is true
you know uh Tyrus uh she should have
been teaching something useful that she
knew like a class on stain
removal okay that's that's not fair we
know that had she known how to do stain
removal they wouldn't have been in this
in the first place and that would have
made Bill Clinton the stupidest
president in the world to bring home
another woman stained dress yeah that's
true and asked his wife to clean
it I'm glad you dissected that well I
just feel at some point someone has to
say yeah okay like he did the right
thing I don't know what you're talking
about if you have any sense at all
listen that that poor
girl apparently she missed the the
trailer that is the Hillary Clinton show
if you thought all of a sudden that she
was going to be this warm
bubbly Charisma or as the kids say risma
yeah that she has never been in the
classroom like hey kids I'm so glad to
be here I'm still bitter about my
marriage and the fact that I lost Donald
Trump but hey everything else is going
swimmingly for me MH I all my shows have
been cancelled on Netflix um I had a
charity foundation and it's not around
anymore uh Bill's still going golfing on
the weekends without his clubs but hey
other than
that let's get some learning done yeah
no she Lally comes in there and says
hello class which one of you is
messaging my
husband I check his DMS to I know it's
you we'll
wait
[Laughter]
class
dismissed you know Shannon uh uh she
discouraged students from asking
questions that's some teacher usually
they want inquisitive students isocratic
method um I think everyone is being too
hard on her because at least she showed
up remember President Biden has told us
numerous times that he taught at Penn
for four years he did get a million
dollars but the Philadelphia inquire
does this thing like he never actually
taught classes there he gave some
lectures and some ticketed items and
that kind of stuff uh so I I mean at
least she came and maybe not for all of
the classes maybe not office hours I
can't imagine that anybody actually
thought she was going to be grading
papers they like exactly how dare
teaching assistants grade our papers I
wanted to share my ideas with her she
they thought they were going to go to
brunch which that's on you not happening
of course she showed up to class she has
nowhere else to go how many times can
she go to the view in one week
yeah I I wonder when she grades papers
or she did she just write what
difference does it
make no GOI call back she writes you'll
shoot your eye
out what um do you think they took the
class just so they could put it on their
resume it's like something that they
could get open a door for them I took
Hillary Clinton's class yeah but I think
on their resume too it's like I worked
for Hillary Clinton right like that's
the way rumes are written nowadays but
the reason people are mad is because it
was a public affairs class they all got
into the class thinking that they were
going to pick and choose which was a
public Affair that Bill had or a private
affair but in actuality she's here and
her the class should have been the two
things she's good at right disappearing
people and and losing right so how do
you be a good loser how do you cover a
crime that should be the class because
none of the People at Columbia are going
to be leaders they're all losers I think
you know so when they said they had all
these cameras there this was content for
another Hillary show and so the students
were actually working for her they were
tricked into being an audience much like
these people here we told this was a
Hannity
show no footballs for
you all right coming up Libs become
unglued when Adam Corola gets
interviewed hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else